déjà pierre première question comment tu
te sens aujourd'hui
c'est horrible cyril est horrible c'est
horrible pour moi c'est surtout horrible
pour ma femme qui se fait insulter dans
des proportions qui dépassent tout ce
qu'on peut me reprocher dans
probablement à juste titre nancy dans ce
documentaire et danser à côté mais voilà
il ya une déferlante de haine de menaces
de mort de 2 à base de rente et organes
j'espère que tu vas aller sur le
trottoir enfin bon alors après je n'ai
peut-être pas je n'ai peut-être pas
volée un renvoi cette séquence tu te dis
quand tu dis que tu as pu dire des
conneries en fait c'est bon dans cette
séquence jeudi une seule connerie c'est
que leurs frais voilà pourquoi parce que
lorsque marie ma scène cette histoire de
jus je suis estomaqué tu te rappelles
plus un musulman rappelle plus mais
maintenant cyril je sais pourquoi je ne
me rappelle plus parce que les faits
puisque ce sont eux faut parler défaite
remonte au 28 août 2016 il se trouve que
le 28 août 2016 ça a été ma dernière
émission avant que je tombe malade et
que je disparaisse des écrans pendant
sept mois donc je pense que ce soir là
je n'étais pas dans mon état normal
tu comprends qu'il ait il suffit
d'ailleurs de voir mon visage qui les
amuse les gens de revoir cette cette
émission avec griezmann ou le voir que
j'étais pas dans mon état normal j'avais
le masque de la mort chemin têtu tu
comprends les gens qui ont été choquées
par à 7,7 ce comportement sur les
réseaux sociaux dans les journalistes
etc
est-ce que tu les comprends maintenant
comportement sur les réseaux sociaux non
sinon voilà ce que les gens qui ont été
choqués par cette séquence que ce soit
les gens sur les réseaux sociaux ou les
journalistes vous été choqué par cette
séquence avec marie sûr quand tu lui a
sauvé la vie parce que tu comprends
aujourd'hui ce que c'est un truc que tu
dis je le referai plus le cinéma bien
sûr mais bien sûr mais bien sûr mais
tout tout tout ce qu'on me reproche que
soit le baiser à isabelle moreau pour la
centième du cfc ça date un ca à 10 ans
tu fais de la télé il ya dix ans je sais
pas combien de personnes a embrassé sur
la bouche il ya dix ans à leurs délires
moi d'ailleurs j'ai embrassé de mg ou
j'ai embrassé francesca je vais pas bien
et mais évidemment quand je jouais à la
scène avec francesca je ferai plus à
aujourd'hui et parce que le monde a
changé ses mythes où on peut plus rien
faire on peut plus rien dire mais ce que
je me ce que jenny dans le dans le dock
et je maintiens c'est que pour moi une
fille un homme c'est pareil et si on ne
peut pas chambrer une fille parce que
c'est une fille pour moi c'est
insupportable mais c'est insupportable
pour elle aussi est d'ailleurs bien sûr
et bien sûr mais dieu sait que francesca
j'ai fait de nombreuses émissions avec
elle et je les chambrer et puis
francesca on a on est beaucoup sortis
ensemble j'ai toujours accepté
j'aimais bien ce que c'est petit et
chambrage c'est vrai que là tu vois tu
parles de ta famille et j'imagine à quel
point cela doit être compliqué
t'imagines quand tu vois cette image
soit moi mon fils aussi pareil c'est
compliqué là il revoit cette image sur
les réseaux sociaux dit maman je me
rappelais plus bien de ce truc explique
moi mais comment ça se fait pour
accepter ça et donc c'est aussi des
trucs comme ma mère pareil donc nous
aussi on en fait c'est juste ça
maintenant il faut qu'on se dise que
voilà faut faire attention parce que
rien faire non mais c'est à dire que moi
moi je pour tout ce qui s'est passé
l'âge et des profonds regrets vraiment
et sincèrement que ce soit profonde
c'est ce qu'a que germe depuis très
longtemps
isabelle marie m'enfin bon mari j'ai
quand même accepté d'y aller faire son
truc
si ça n'a pas été diffusée c'est pas de
mon ressort c'est un choix et avec ce
onzième à diffuser à non gérés j'ai rien
demandé d'amender d'accord j'ai rien
demandé moi je vais pas été geste a été
choqué par par le contenu j'ai été très
étonné de ce type par deux juges puisque
encore une fois je n'en ai aucun
souvenir
mais j'ai pas été choqué quand on a
toujours parlé des images de toits avec
francesca avec isabelle moreau est ce
que tu comprends que ça fasse polémique
ou pas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui oui à l'époque ça n'a pas
fait polémique à l'époque quand
j'embrasse isabelle moreau pour la
centième du cfc tout le plateau est
hilare tout le public applaudit dans
cette scène là c'est pareil aujourd'hui
ça fera un scandale affreux les seuils d
embrasser kelly sont la bouche tout à
l'heure tu verras que ça passera
à alors qu'il ya cinq ans ça serait pas
ces crèmes est-ce que tu considères déjà
pour toi pierre est-ce que tu considères
avant avoir déjà eu des comportements
déplacés sur des plateaux avec des défis
ou patrick des femmes avec des filles
avec des voilà est-ce que ça comme je
les 10 matches dans ma vie
professionnelle a été jalonnée de filles
j'ai suivi le psg à l'équipe et frédéric
gala mais ensuite j'ai enchaîné avec
estelle denis
après il ya eu la belle moreau nathalie
iannetta astrid bard frantsesenia est
elle maintenant il ya leur boulot
toutes les filles qui ont fait 19 heures
30 pm avec moi et j'ai jamais eu et j'ai
jamais eu de problème avec personne
c'est pour ça que je regrette
profondément l'image que certaines
personnes
alors je parle pas des gens forcément
super mal intentionnés qui toutes façons
trouveront toujours quelque chose à
redire
j'ai une polémique la semaine dernière
sur le cambriolage de di maria
c'était quasiment aussi violent quand
est ce que quand aujourd'hui tout le
monde associe son nom à un mauvais
comportement avec les femmes
est ce que est ce que c'est quand tu lis
ce que mal mal parce que c'est pas moi
parce que c'est pas moi je suis pas
comme ça et les gens qui me connaissent
le savent
c'est d'ailleurs rigolo hier j'ai reçu
que des messages d'insultés puis là au
fil de la journée ça commence à tourner
je commence à recevoir des messages de
soutien je parle pas de mes proches qui
est évidemment savent très bien comment
je suis mais ouais c'est se fonder des
trucs regrettable mais c'est des trucs
qui datent marie portolano après cette
séquence eux dont elle a parlé est-ce
que vous en avions parlé ensemble
jamais jamais après après le dock ou
après la classe
après l'asie jamais après la juge allait
jamais j'ai découvert ce qui se vend des
jus ce jour là d'accord donc je n'avais
déjà pas elle tend même parodie après
jamais mais elle pourrait être vue que
s'ils avaient marqué pas du tout mais tu
savais pas du tout qu'elle est parvenue
jeudi que j'ai aucun aucun souvenir de
cette de cette scène j'ai même aucun
souvenir de cette émission
donc voilà gilbert des mois ce que les
pierres depuis très longtemps
c'est quelqu'un qui est d'abord qui est
toujours là je tiens à dire c'est un ami
toujours là dans les mauvais moments
mais là n'est pas le débat mais il est à
l'emporte-pièce pierre c'est à dire que
il a des foucades des emportements
positif ou négatif
parfois c'est peut-être sont des faucons
qualifiée à l'époque de bof c'est à dire
qu'il est capable de gestes qui
parraissent déplacés aujourd'hui ce que
je tiens à dire c'est que
travaille avec lui depuis plus de vingt
ans et il est sans limite
il n'a aucun filtre pierres et parfois
parfois non mais parfois parfois ça
dérape dans le langage là dans les
gestes etc
donc ça ce n'est pas acceptable bien
entendu mais c'est quelqu'un qui
fondamentalement et comme il est avec
tout le monde
voilà bien aujourd'hui je suis d'accord
avec ce que vient de dire gilles et et
j'y travaille j'y travaille parce que la
société a changé et que ce que je
pouvais me permettre il ya dix ou cinq
ans je peux plus malheureusement dans le
jeu leurs bêtes
je le regrette parce que je me freine
mais je peux presque tout ce déferlement
sur les réseaux dont les dons les médias
est ce qu'aujourd'hui tu te serait
excusé de son comportement est ce que tu
te dis non franchement ça passe je vois
pas le problème mais je le dis à maric
je suis désolé dans le dogme je lui dis
mais pas ce que mais malheureusement
quand elle me le dis je la prends je la
prends à ce moment là mais je lui dis je
suis désolé parce qu'effectivement c'est
pas normal pas normal je ne peux même
pas m'expliquer comment j'ai pu faire ça
qu'est ce que tu as dit afin qu'elle
soit alors hier soir chantreau cfc 12h30
aujourd'hui a dit que j'en avais parlé
qu'est-ce que bah elle me soutient comme
toujours tu la connais
voilà et puis mais elle me dit de faire
attention à mon comportement parce
qu'elle est là aussi elle c'est comme je
suis quoi donc
et c'est vrai qu'il faut que je veux
lire c'est vrai que j'ai d'ailleurs il
faut que je modifie des choses mais j'ai
déjà modifié beaucoup de choses depuis
un moment guillaume ajoute la séquence
qu'on a vu c'est incroyable je
m'attendais à voir une femme qui
accusait un homme d'harcèlement sexuel
en fait c'est une discussion posé entre
deux causes anciens collègues de travail
sur un débat de société sur harry est ce
qu'on peut dire et qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire avec une femme aujourd'hui voilà
je trouve que pierre ménès il a beaucoup
de courage d'avoir été dans cette
séquence où c'est pas facile
il a beaucoup de courage d'être sur le
plateau ce soir parce que c'est pas
facile non plus et pardon mais moi aussi
j'ai lu des horreurs sur les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
gens qui parlent de viol pardon mais les
faits qui lui sont reprochés
ce n'est pas un viol c'est pas un viol
allez allez dire aux gens qu'ils ont
subi vraiment un violent que ça c'est un
viol c'est pas vrai que ce soit déplacé
oui que ce soit gênant oui il le
regrette il a le courage de venir sur un
plateau pour s'exprimer sur ça mais je
suis désolé et francesca j'aime beaucoup
son témoignage parce qu'elle est très
mesuré dans ce qu'elle dit on voit
clairement qu'elle n'a pas envie qu'on
parle d'elle pour cette histoire elle
raconte sa vérité et pardon mais elle le
dit elle n'a pas ressenti comme une
agression sexuelle donc j'imagine encore
moins comme angers mais quand tu as well
as c koi tu étais général qu'est ce que
je suis gêné parce que c'est l'image qui
me plaît que j'ai des bons souvenirs
avec pierrot et qu' on est copains et
que voilà et que cette salle ça me soule
qui est tout ce buzz autour de ça parce
que effectivement il n'aurait pas dû
faire ça et franchement sans le moment
ça m'a humilié et il sait très bien
qu'il ya des fois des trucs qu'il a pu
dire qu'ils m'ont qui m'ont fait de la
peine qui m'ont blessé mais mais c'est
puis c'est pas une belle image voilà
c'est nul ça n'a pas d'intérêt
voilà donc ça me fait chier content
d'être là pour parler de ça mais en même
temps je me dois de le dire il faut
aussi que ça passe pas il faut aussi que
les la parole se libère il faut pouvoir
parler faut pouvoir dire les choses et
puis voilà hier contentant francesca qui
je suis gêné parce que c'est vrai que tu
me disais qu'à ton fils
toi tu pensais qu au chaud en ce moment
là avec francesca avec marié youtube
c'était une émission quand même très
spécial c'est les producteurs
producteurs il est quand même une
émission sa déco des blues de déconne
bien sûr que de sport
effectivement je sais pas que ce que
c'était ce pari que j'avais
j'ai aucun souvenir de ça non plus mais
oui effectivement aujourd'hui ça n'a pas
lieu d'être quand même aujourd'hui
ces images sont scandaleux quand tu vois
les hashtag qui a eu aujourd'hui sur toi
qui sont les violons est-ce que ça
est-ce que c'est énormément touché pour
ta famille pour toi ski j'ai vu des
attaques passées
voilà qui était très loin guillaume
quitte à regarder
oui on m'a ont massé rapidement intimé
l'ordre d'arrêter de regarder ce que
j'ai fait franchement quelque part je le
mérite un peu je le mérite un peu parce
que les images qui passent notamment
l'image de francesca même si elles sont
pas récentes
elles sont aujourd'hui au moment où on
se parle aujourd'hui elles sont oui
elles sont choquantes
donc je je je peux pas comprendre les
insultes je peux pas comprendre les
menaces de mort mais je peux comprendre
comme critique de façon même assez
violente puis radié oui j'aime bien ce
que vous dites là ce que vous venez de
dire là parce qu'effectivement pour moi
selon moi vous n'êtes pas là ce estime
effectivement quand vous soulevez une
jeep
j'ai jamais dit que j'étais là vie non
mais c'est ma posture de peach ou à la
non mais quand cyril vous dis c'est dur
ce que vous avez vécu aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est beaucoup plus dur pour
les jeunes filles que vous avez
peut-être embrasse est fort soit qui
vous avez soulevé la jupe c'est parce
que ce que je veux dire c'est que je
vous ai entendu c'est vrai que c'est
guillaume a raison c'est un moment très
fort mais le côté on ne peut plus rien
dire où ça va c'était pas méchant où ça
va c'était drôle ou attention on peut
plus rien dire
je trouve que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
pierre et vous le dit très bien le
logiciel 2021 ne peut plus longtemps
qu'en fait je choque voilà effectivement
étonnant est que quand bien même dans
cette partie là du doc vous dit
finalement ben oui bon mais c'est pas
grave et tout ça je faisais ça pour
rigoler ça c'est inaudible
c'est à dire qu'on te plus longtemps
c'est inacceptable c'est juste ça qu'a
changé et je suis heureuse de vous
entends dire ce soir que finalement ben
voila vous vous ne pourriez plus le
faire géraldine sauf que les faits qui
lui sont reprochés
il dote de
10 en six ans et oui mais il ya dix ans
ce n'était pas normal de le d'eux mêmes
il ya 10 ans de se soulever la gym
fitness cochet symbole non pardon c'est
pas normal
son média certains mensonges alors donc
à l'avancé sa lan n'a jamais dit ça l a
jamais dit vous avez changé mais fière
elle n'a jamais dit ça je n'ai jamais
dit qu'elle était en stream elle a des
qualités a dit oui quel est ton stream
prévu le ministère de l'intérieur a
réagi à l'approché pire voilà ils disent
embrasser quelqu'un de force par
surprise lui attraper les fesses sur un
plateau tv dans les transports au
travail quel que soit le contexte il
s'agit d'une agression sexuelle puni par
la loi et il ya marlène schiappa car
réagi regarde si vous voulez moi
personnellement les images avec pierre
ménès sur brasse de force le journaliste
je les trouve très choquante lui trouve
profondément choquant je le dis à
plusieurs reprises dans plusieurs
émissions sur d'autres faire il ya des
phénomènes qui sont graves qu'on ne doit
pas à banaliser
oui c'est choquant qu'un journaliste
sportif profite de sa notoriété et
profite du fait qu'on soit en direct
pour commettre des agressions sexuelles
et ensuite faire passer les victimes de
ces agressions sexuelles pour des gens
qui manqueraient d'humour parce que ça
ne les fait pas rigoler de se faire
agresser sexuellement en direct sur un
plateau de télévision
oui c'est le far west en mai dernier
qu'elle manquait d'humour ou est ce que
j'ai dit qu'elle manquait d'humour non
mais quand on voit la bombe est tombée
ça c'est voit la moitié en fait voilà
vous déconnez pascalou reprendra les
chats page conspirent s'est dit quand
vous votre argument de dire je déconne
autant avec les garçons kavala voilà je
passais mon temps elle n'avait pas
entendu c'est oui mais je pense qu'à
elle elle parlait de ça si dans le
documentaire milliards aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous avez
qu'est ce que vous pourriez dire
aujourd'hui est ce que ça vous a fait
prendre conscience hier que ce que vous
aviez fait avec marie était grave ou est
ce que vous voudrez quand vous avez
tourné le documentaire vous êtes dit en
rentrant chez vous j'ai l'impression que
marielle a été marqué par par ce qui
s'était passé joie honnêtement quand je
suis rentré du documentaire j'ai essayé
quand même un peu de fouiller dans ma
mémoire et de retrouver ces
cette séquence ce qu'aujourd'hui encore
je ne parviens pas à faire mais
maintenant je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
j'ai explications de ça mais comme je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure je me suis
parfaitement conscient que tout ce qui
est tout ce qui m'est reproché et qui
est ancien comme le dit géraldine c'est
intolérable dans le logiciel 2021 je
voudrais dire aux téléspectateurs aux
twittos ce jour aux gens qui vous qui
qui ont été choquées et qui ont l'ont
fait savoir sur les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous avez à
leur dire si vous écoute ce soir j'ai
alors dire qu'ils ont raison de ils ont
raison d'être en colère ils ont raison
de m'en vouloir que j'ai j'ai beaucoup
changé depuis
depuis malgré fin pour être très clair
ça fait quatre ans et demi et je suis
parvenu le même que j'étais à ce niveau
là je suis beaucoup plus économes
apaisées et que de toute façon on ne
reprendra plus jamais à faire des choses
comme ça vous regrettez tout ça oui
profondément à wipro foule avait dit à
marie aussi oui je suis humain je
regrette je le redit hier par sms parce
qu'on avait changé en fait j'ai pas
regardé le documentaire est fière parce
qu'il y avait lille nîmes en même temps
quand même mon travail et j'ai quand
même commencer à voir une déferlante de
haine sur tous les amoureux où vous
l'avez aussi parce qu'il y avait ici des
épisodes 10 avec nous aussi
isabelle a dit voilà qu elle aussi s
étend des pales été un peu choqué vous
l'avez aussi isabelle moreau pas
récemment mais depuis lé depuis
l'interview avec
avec marie oui francesca camp quand vous
entendez pierre on vous avait dit alors
que vous voyez ces images au départ vous
vous rendez pas compte de voilà que
c'était voilà ça pouvait avoir des
conséquences derrière est aujourd'hui
convenu d'agir au mieux vous avez dit
que vous étiez gêné quand vous entendez
les excuses de pierre est-ce que vous ça
ça ça vous touche est ce que ça vous ça
vous permet de 2.2 aussi de voilà de
d'oublier cette c contre possible
non mais la prise de conscience de toute
façon c'est le début du changement donc
c'est important voilà que nous mais je
parle de pierre mais il ya deux
journalistes dans ce milieu là qui
parfois peuvent avoir des comportements
qui nous blesse à nous mais peut-être
qu'ils s'en rendent pas comptent donc
pour prendre conscience que parfois on
peut humilier des gens eybens et voilà
c'est le début du changement et
l'important c'est que la parole se
libère que nous on puisse voilà on put
parler que les femmes qui subissent des
trucs un peu compliqué puisse en parler
et après voilà les choses et choses
évoluent encore une fois je le garde le
respect que j'ai pour pierre c'était
important qu'ils s'excusent important
parce qu'il ya plein de femmes qui
attendent d'entendre ça aussi donc voilà
il l'a fait après c'est plus important
vous avez eu des mots durs aussi envers
les journalistes percer ce qu on dit
aujourd'hui paraît que voilà sur les
réseaux tout ça qu'est ce que vous avez
à leur dire ce qui vous sont tombés
dessus etc
vous voulez réagir peu de tout et
peinture qui me disent je suis arrivé
devant le studio est une équipe de bfm
qui m'attendait je peux concevoir
l'importance et la gravité de ces choses
je trouve que placer dans le conseil
dans le golfe dans ce qui se passe au
niveau national ça me paraît malgré tout
être une forme de détails
donc voilà je pense que le sujet que
vous avez traité avant avec la manif à
marseille était d'un point de vue
national autrement plus important que ça
mais voilà je suis connue je suis
clivant je suis chroniqueur numéro de
l'émission de foot numéro un dans
quelque part je suis l'homme à abattre
il faut juste que je fasse attention à
prêter le flanc à sa juste je vous dis
ce qui se passe sur les réseaux si
pierre même temps qu'est ce que vous
répondez aux gens qui disent en fait il
sait qu'ils s'excusaient pierre il à ce
comportement parce que juste il a
peut-être eu peur d'être voilà ils sont
c'est du canal football club avec ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui avec ce que vous
répondez aux gens qui disent que vous
faites ça plus par l'intérêt que par
conviction je vous dis toutes les
questions comme ça va voilà tu as raison
écoute j'ai eu une chance inouïe c'est
d'être aimé et soutenu par ma chaîne qui
me l'a prouvé quand j'étais en train de
mourir qui me le prouve chaque jour
depuis
c'est une chaîne à laquelle je suis
profondément attaché voilà entre canal
et moi c'est une histoire d'amour et c1
mais quand les gens disent ils ont fait
ça parce qu'il a peur d'être personnes
personne ne m'a dit ça personne ne m'a
dit faut que tu ailles la pêche à nouna
sinon à conduire et voilà non mais c'est
important dire puisqu il ya des gens de
guily et et quand un juge elle brise
virait ce matin le directeur des
antennes
voilà vers 9h toi qui m'a dit ah serait
peut-être bien que jeanne mas j'ai
réservé ma réponse je ne savais pas
j'avais de sedan dans cette histoire
j'avais deux solutions soit je faisais
le mort
soit jaune et m'expliquer j'ai pris des
conseils tout là toute la journée et
puis voilà vos excuses et vos regrets
son sein sont sincères tu me connais
cyril freebox est bien jeune et bien
fait jamais rien tu sais bien que je
suis jamais rien ne passe à faire
géraldine dernière question pour pierre
et pierre comme vous dites que vous êtes
soutenus par votre chaîne est ce que
vous trouvez que c'est une bonne chose
qu'ils aient coupé votre séquence dans
le documentaire de marie est ce que ça
vous protéger comme assistant et celle
de pierre ils ont découpé
tout laisse toute présence masculine 3
dans manager dans ma vie c'est ma
dernier bateau et toi et moi et
au niveau éditorial canal+ a estimé que
ce n'était pas une émission d' enquête
mais c'était une émission de témoignages
et que dans ce cas là la parole des
femmes était beaucoup plus fort s'il n'y
avait que des femmes moi très
franchement gerling vu ce que je vis
aujourd'hui vous serez prêt qui leur est
difficile à gérer que la fée cov reste
dans les cercles d'insurgés a été
certainement beaucoup moins d'attaqués
exactement